hey guys how are you I'm Justine welcome
back to my kitchen today we're going to
be doing something really fun this is
going to be a little DIY slash cooking
video now everything that I'm going to
be doing today is inspired by these new
coffee-mate holiday flavors but there's
a little bit of a backstory to this
because my ex-boyfriend actually just
moved to Los Angeles and he now started
working at coffee-mate so we just
actually reconnected and I went to his
house and we baked some cookies so you
guys want to check out that video I'll
put a link in the description I wanted
to make Joel some little presents sort
of like a little you know welcome to Los
Angeles
inspired by the new coffee meat flavors
so what we're gonna do is first of all
we're peppermint mocha I'm going to make
him a cute little peppermint outfit for
Gingerbread I'm gonna make some
gingerbread cookies but I don't have any
gingerbread cookie cutters here because
I was never allowed to have those in the
house when I was with Joel for good
reason pumpkin spice I'm going to be
making Joel a cute little pumpkin for
the holidays and I'm gonna just not
really sure what's gonna happen here but
I've got some crafts some bedazzles
maybe I'll bedazzle a pumpkin I don't
know and for eggnog I'm going to make
some egg nog inspired cupcakes first
things first we're going to make the
cupcakes and the cookies at the same
time so while those are baking I can
start doing the other parts of the
crafts they're gonna be little tiny
cupcakes cuz Jules may he's you know
he's like a tall so we're gonna put this
in the bowl like so okay I have coffee
okay my coffee is brewing and now I'm
gonna just figure out what else I need I
need 102 3 1 cup of water 1/4 cup of oil
it's a little little bit much there we
go just use this
Kofi oh that's amazing
that's just delicious
so those are in there that's not all now
hmm just fill this up
so while we're putting these in I'm
going to start on the gingerbread
cookies I've got some gingerbread dough
already made because let me tell you
I've done that from scratch before and
it's not fun gingerbread cookie dough
balls and I'm going to turn them into a
man that will be a head wonder how this
is gonna work out
I think Joel will like it it's actually
a little bit taller than Joel but I
don't know alright so while our cakes
are cooking and cookies are cooking the
first thing I'm gonna make for the
peppermint mocha is I want to make Joel
like a maybe like a shirt and you want
to cut it in the shape of a shirt I just
don't have Joel's measurements right now
so I'm not really sure okay isn't it all
teeny tiny shirt and when I think of
peppermint mocha I think of like a light
like a light brown so I've got some
colors oh that means I gotta check them
cakes not done so I think for the shirt
I want to put like a nice little brown
mocha Ridge on it like here that also
like on the sleeves and you can just
glue it down put that right there
I think don't like the stripes oh good
I'm so good Joel I may be something I
might make the white a little bit bigger
so that it'll stick just a real nice
peppermint mocha shirt looks a little
bit better Oh looks beautiful place your
pumpkin like that just a nice little
something we're going to take this
pumpkin sticker and we're going to place
the pumpkin sticker over top of the
pumpkin I don't know why look at that
very creative extremely creative this is
really exciting because I've got three
other little pumpkins we're gonna write
Joel's name in some sparkly stickers
he's gonna love it Joel oh do you think
he's gonna like it
I wanted to carve a pumpkin for Joel but
none of the pumpkin patches had pumpkins
they were small enough that I could fit
into his house so original so unique
here's our cupcakes now these are gonna
be really fun because I'm going to turn
them into many little eggs files at a
craft store I saw these little tiny
bacon candies and I thought hmm
so first steps is we're gonna want to
put some white icing oops
cool the last one was like perfect
continuing on with these little guys you
want to just make a nice little round
circle somewhere to kind of make it look
like a broken little eggie we're gonna
put little little Bacon's on them
they're candy Bacon's guys look at these
they're so cute Wow when you take a
picture I'm proud
everything is going so very well until I
show you what I made over here hmm
yeah I think the only way to resolve
this is to I'm sorry I'm sorry for
ruining my gingerbread cookie and Joel
I'm also sorry for our relationship not
working out bring it around full circle
thank you guys so much for watching this
video I had so much fun making all of
these fun little things I'll see you
guys in the next video if you happen to
recreate any of the things that I did
here today make sure you send me a
picture or if you end up finding
anivia's at your grocery store or you
have them at your home already send me a
picture of that as well and I will see
you guys on the Internet and in the next
video so bye